hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the ed talks version
of our homeroom
with sal live stream we have a very
exciting conversation today with laverne
srinivasan but before we get into that
conversation i will give my standard
reminders first of all we are a
not-for-profit we can only exist through
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate donations of all sizes make a
huge difference and allow us to deliver
khan academy to hundreds of millions of
people around the world i also want to
make a special shout out to several
organizations that stepped up especially
during the pandemic when they realized
that more people than ever were leaning
on khan academy
which also meant our costs were going up
our server costs and our desire to to
accelerate a whole bunch of programs so
special thanks to bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors and then last but not least there
is a podcast version of this live stream
available wherever you get your podcast
on homeroom with sal the podcast so
definitely check that out so with that i
am excited to introduce laverne
sreenivasan who is vice president and
director of education at the carnegie
corporation uh full disclosure full
disclosure also a funder of khan academy
so i am somewhat biased
but laverne
great great great to see you thanks for
joining us
great to see you too so pleasure to be
here
well maybe a good place to start
for those who haven't heard and i'm sure
there aren't many
what does the carnegie corporation of
new york do and what does the director
of education do within that context
absolutely carnegie corporation of new
york is actually a foundation that has
invested in knowledge to inspire
informed action since 1911.
we actually invest in democracy
international peace and security and in
education and for my role in the
education program we are focused on
ensuring that our american public
education system serves all students by
building the knowledge skills and
dispositions that they need to be active
participants in our democracy and and
and be able to thrive and engage fully
in our economy
so we have five grant making portfolios
but our strategy is really focused on
making sure
that
parents and and educators can be full
partners in transforming the learning
experience we think it's absolutely
critical that our best hope for
having an equitable and transformed
learning environment is by fully
engaging the adults and building their
capacity and also ensuring that they can
work in a system that's optimized to
ensure their effectiveness including
making sure that their actions are
informed uh by knowledge that's been
developed in the field so our five
portfolios are
new designs to advance learning where we
focus on innovations in classrooms and
schools to promote
better student learning and youth
development we also focus on pathways to
post-secondary success where we
reimagine pathways for high school
graduates including access and
completion of college and better
aligning k-12 higher ed and the end
careers we have another portfolio
focused on leadership and teaching to
advanced learning where we focus on high
quality curriculum and
strengthening teaching and learning to
implement
that high quality
standards standards-aligned curriculum
along with professional learning we also
have a
portfolio that focuses on family
engagement it's a public understanding
portfolio where we're really looking to
have a shared understanding of how
all of the adults in the system can work
together along with students to
transform
the learning environment and lastly we
have an integration learning and
innovation portfolio and in that
portfolio is where we really inspire uh
all folks who are
essential in transforming our nation's
education system to develop strategies
and implement them in complex systems
and and share the learning associated
with that and foster collaboration so
those are our five portfolios though
and and and and that was super helpful
and i just want to remind everyone
watching especially those who are
watching live if you have any questions
for laverne or myself we want to get to
them so please put them in the message
board under wherever you're watching
this facebook youtube wherever
but lauren on on this focus on education
you know i'm curious about where you are
most excited where you're most hopeful
and especially where what has has the
last year changed your perspective on
anything given all of the disruption
that has happened uh to to education
because of the pen that
yes so i i feel we
we've really reflected on this deeply
because there has been so much
disruption and there are so many people
who are
uh really struggling and have struggled
and and also people who have had
incredible experiences but
in our within our work we realized that
so many of the aspects of
the focus in our five portfolios are
turning out to be really important
aspects of places schools school systems
that have been able to pivot and adjust
and adapt effectively in in this
disrupted environment so
in particular i'd say one of our newer
portfolios although we've been invested
now for six years in family engagement
that's been a real uh area of priority
for us and one that has been essential
in helping our through our grantees
respond to the challenges that families
have faced with the tsunami of resources
coming at them to the extent that they
have them but also really connecting
with their teachers their schools and
school environments and and our grantees
have really i think stepped up
incredibly well to help all parents and
schools teachers and educators uh
connect with families in more meaningful
ways so we're excited about the
possibilities that this
has in continuing to build commitment
and and to build on the strength of
what's happened over the last
year so that we'd no longer
operate in a way that has some
artificial constraints and walls around
schools that don't effectively in the
past did not effectively engage parents
as well in communities as well as they
could have
and we have two questions that that
double click on what you just talked
about you know from you to both
questions from youtube susana garcia
dominguez who's a regular on on the show
so to speak almost view her as a co-host
of sorts but she she i've never met her
in person but i look forward to one day
uh says hi laverne please share some of
the most innovative projects you support
thanks for all you do from youtube suheb
alaska alaska also saying what are some
of the projects you support in what way
so especially with this parent
engagement
why do you think there was a gap to
begin with and what what are some of the
efforts that y'all are supporting that
you think could close this gap because
it does seem in some ways obvious that
like the parent is an incredibly
important actor
for for children's learning
yeah i think we historically focused in
school systems on parent engagement is
is just an activity where we were
inviting parents to come at the very
least for parent-teacher conferences
maybe for bake sales and other
activities but there hasn't always been
and this is you can't paint the entire
country with one broad brush stroke
around this but you know i think that a
lot of efforts were involving bringing
parents into the school environment to
participate in some
particularly focused way and i think the
difference in what we have seen in the
last year and by the way the research
has no we've known through research for
quite some time that parent engagement
is essential to improving student
outcomes so what we've seen
is for example you know efforts that we
supported that home school connection
engagement isn't just about you know
showing up in schools on school time
parents have busy schedules not every
parent can come in
at the prescribed times that schools
invite them in so how do we create an
environment where there is a more
dynamic engagement between home and
school one of our grantees that is
really strong in this area is power my
learning where they've created an
innovative app that allows children to
demonstrate what they're learning in
school by actually
basically teaching it to a caregiver or
parent or other adult in their homes
or outside of the school environment so
it really triangulates in a way that
home school
teacher parent and student learning uh
and and and creates a more um you know
bi-directional
engagement that
fosters a more inclusive learning
environment so those are the kinds of
things we can do i mean during the the
pandemic there are also
um
you know efforts that helped with
translation you know whether or helped
parents understand how to read to their
children like springboard collaborative
so there are i could i as a matter of
fact we actually have a number of these
resources on our website that we tried
to help curate
for busy families who also couldn't work
through the tsunami of resources and
started flowing their way so i think the
real secret cell and what i hope we will
see going
looking different going forward is a
better
understanding of where families are and
meeting them where they are in a more
authentic way as opposed to just to let
us invite you into our four walls
you know i love that example you gave
you know i've always been a huge
advocate and supporter that
some students are are could actually be
incredible teachers and to to at least
tutors maybe i should say and to maybe
leverage them within a classroom to
tutor each other or to tutor younger
peers but it sounds like y'all are
taking it further with some of your your
grantees to to say why can't the
students tutor their parents uh which
which i think is a very very very
powerful idea because it is
you know i always cringe when a parent
but i understand at the same time when
they say oh well i haven't seen this
since fourth grade i was like yeah but
you went to fifth grade in sixth grade
and but but there is sometimes this fear
of parents to even engage but this
almost this this kind of flips the
things in in a really interesting
interesting way what are your you know
you've been in the field of philanthropy
in the field of education for a while
and
you know i
i i i like you i'm very optimistic about
where the world can go but there's also
sometimes cynicism that people have been
working on this problem for a while
they've been putting throwing money at
different parts of the problem but
at least from some vantage points it
looks like it hasn't moved the dial
do you agree with some of that cynicism
do you have some fears um and how in the
philanthropic world do y'all
maybe even learn from some of
you know it might not be things you all
have done but stuff that happened in the
past and what are those learnings
yeah that's a great question sal um
you're right i i want to be optimistic
but i also want to be realistic and
the
we we really have a big challenge in
front of us i found myself thinking that
we have to get out of our comfort zones
we all have to grapple with new ideas
and engage in effectively a design
challenge where instead of gravitating
to just siloed solutions that we really
start to look at the full ecosystem of
learning and the in center children and
families in that
as authentic partners in it and
designers in it but also to recognize
that you know we can't all in the
education sector uh you know get
attached to the thing that we think is
the most effective or likely to be uh
the most highly effective solution to
addressing uh the change we need to see
in education or to better meet student
learning needs so i think one of the
things we have to learn is is less
fragmentation more collaboration
much better sharing of learning
understanding that it's not just what we
do that matters but how we do it that
matters those i think are going to be
essential in making change and you know
aligning resources aligning that highly
effective um
curriculum with aligned professional
learning keeping and considering that
adults and students make up that
learning environment that we really need
to to transform to to really lean into a
future that that that is going to thrive
on lifelong learning and so if our
learning environments aren't more porous
inside of school outside of school at
home learning happens in all of those
environments and how we
really
take ourselves out of our comfort zone
to really think and imagine a way that
we can
knit together the positive and promising
proof points and solutions that we've
seen
to
actually support
adults and students to to thrive in in a
transformed and more equitable learning
environment and a learning ecosystem
yeah it sounds like one of the key
takeaways has been
it's not just what happened obviously
what happens in the classroom is
incredibly important but what goes on
beyond the classroom especially the
family and you know related to that the
pandemic introduced a lot of disruption
but people explored things like pod
schooling and homeschooling and distance
learning and for a lot of folks that
didn't work but for some it seems like
at least parts of it might and related
that there's a question from youtube
shraddha padwa asks hey laverne what do
you think about homeschool learning in
normal school and i'll just add to that
do you think
we're we're kind of going to start
hybridizing in certain ways uh you know
that that's kind of the ultimate
bringing the home into the classroom
yeah i think that um
i think that what happened with pods is
really uh really compelling i in many
ways you know i think people are focused
on the fact that there were pods but
what were what did pods represent i mean
pods represented
another opportunity
to
bring community and families together
again
understanding better what's necessary to
support their students and their
children and their learning and and a
little bit more of a strategy around how
you can focus that in smaller groups
well you we can learn from that both in
the classroom but we can also learn that
not everyone learns the same way
individual
you know
paying attention to the individual needs
of students
allows you all of a sudden to open your
mind and realize that learning in
classrooms can be
approached differently in and we do it
now that it happens in small pods in
schools with attention from one teacher
and ability to accelerate learning while
others are are finishing learning that
that they're not uh as fully uh advanced
in yet so i think that you know i think
homeschooling is something that works
extraordinarily well for some families
and i think families know best what's
what's going to work for their kids but
i think again that making it more porous
realizing that there's something that we
can all learn by centering the needs of
students and the needs that that
specific students have for their
learning and to advance not only their
academic development but their
socio-emotional development as well i
think are what's going to make the
difference in whether we learn from this
experience and advance our conception of
what learning is and where it takes
place or whether we stay rooted in a
compliance oriented industrial age
education system
makes a lot of sense and there's another
question here i guess this is a question
for both of us from facebook mir nalani
prabhu says hi sal and laverne please
listen in order what i as a parent tutor
can do for student success uh so i i'll
let you take a stab at it i have i have
some ideas too yeah
as a student tutor um well i guess it
depends on what they're tutoring in i
think that it's important for a parent
or tutor is i think she's saying that
you know as a essentially as a parent
what can i do like right now to help my
kids exactly okay i think i think some
of there's some really great resources
out out there um i think and sal is
probably going to give us some of those
also from his perspective the wide open
school which is actually one of our
grantees has some incredible resources
that were curated there for parents and
activities and depending on the level
your child is at you will find what you
know different resources that will help
you understand what should my child know
uh at this level and what activities or
other strategies can i use to make sure
that i help them
at home continue to advance and learn uh
along the pathway that they're on in
addition there are also other resources
whether it's great schools
again i invite you to go to our website
as well not as a commercial for our
website
but to say we have tried to thoughtfully
curate some of these things that we
think will help parents navigate
and if you have young children reading
is so essential how
having the opportunity to read with your
child
uh is one of the most critical things
that you can certainly do
so yeah no i i love all of those and i
will add uh
things that will not surprise anyone but
you know khan academy as i tell
everybody who will listen if you're able
to work with your children i don't know
how old they are but we go down all the
way to khan academy kids all the way
through especially kind of academy kids
covers math reading writing social
emotional learning but then you know
math we have very comprehensive all the
way through middle high school college
level mathematics and they're pretty
consistent you know we have 50 efficacy
studies that if students even put in 45
minutes a week it grows them 20 30 in
some cases 50 more than expected so if
you're able to if your child is able to
put in i would say 15 minutes a day
which is very doable
you know you can help motivate them as a
parent
in in two or three months i will be
surprised if you don't see a massive
difference otherwise i will give a
personal money back guarantee partially
joking but even if we did charge you i
would i would stand behind that with a
money back guarantee and and uh the
other is an effort
i can vouch as a parent as a parent i've
actually used khan academy with my child
as well
oh well no i actually we've talked about
that before and i actually that's i
think our most powerful you know even
when we talk to philanthropists if the
philanthropist sees it works for their
family they're like hey it could work
for a lot of a lot of folks family
but the other effort uh is is an effort
which is that you could do this as a
spin-off of khan academy or
complimentary effort called
schoolhouse.world for free tutoring so
if your child is 13 or over they can
either get free tutoring right now it's
math and sat but it's going to exp and
actually it's expanded into the sciences
and ap subjects as well
but also
if they once they really master concepts
they can give tutoring uh to other
people which is analogous to what
laverne was saying about the power when
you teach others not only are you
helping them but but you're helping
yourself so
there's a lot of resources now and it's
just about making sense of them and and
and doing them consistently you know
it's it's all about we're all guilty of
like i'm going to play guitar and i'm
going to do 10 hours today and then it
drifts away but it's all about if you do
15 20 minutes a day for a long period of
time it makes a huge difference so
laverne and these conversations always
go faster than i expect but i also want
to you know kind of understand a little
bit of your background what got you into
this field how did you
get into philanthropy education in
particular um
yeah how did you get here
sure
well
i was fortunate enough to grow up in a
family that absolutely
you thought education was the most
important thing and i am so grateful
school every day for that and that has
had me on a lifelong journey of whether
it was tutoring
younger kids or
working while i was in college to set up
opportunities in communities to work
with young people with computers and
helping them do exactly what we're
talking about now which is sort of out
of school learning that's something or
being a mentor that those are all things
that i did
while i wasn't in education as a career
but what inspired me to get into
education and stay in education is
actually using my skills and background
from a private sector experience that i
had and to
think about how to transform the system
and transforming a complex system like
education is really hard to do but it
gets it gets a little bit more realistic
to believe it can be done which is what
i've seen
when you actually center students and
families in communities and you design
from that perspective it really you
really have to get we really have to
stretch ourselves to get out of our
compliance-oriented approach to
education because that's not the
expansive
learning environment and ecosystem we
need to succeed so that my family
inspired me my teachers inspired me
those who brought everything to life in
the classroom whether it was an english
class or a science class
all of that has led me to say i want
everyone to have the opportunity that i
feel like i was fortunate enough to have
and on that last point as we ramp into
teacher appreciation week
i'm i'm curious are there any teachers
that you you you know i'm sure many
teachers that you want to appreciate but
i need to come to mind that that you
know you really made a lasting impact on
you
yeah i i will say um
i want to appreciate all teachers um
just because my one of the things that
i've done in education is really focus
on how important teachers are so first
shout out to all teachers you are all
special and i hope in this time of covid
when everyone has had to get so much
closer to understanding what teaching is
all about and what it means for their
kids that we all appreciate all of you
more in particular i'll shout out ronnie
clemmer and beverly hannett they were
both english teachers of mine and in it
one in middle school and one in high
school and they just brought every book
to life for me made it relevant made it
engaging and really
contributed to sort of my lifelong uh
love of reading
no that's great i mean i think you know
the the teachers in our lives that have
made a difference um yeah i mean it just
keeps going and unfortunately they don't
they don't hear probably about it enough
because you know maybe when you're in
middle school or high school
we're not always there to say hey
teacher you've changed my life but then
when we're in our 30s and 40s and 50s
we're like wow uh it'd be incredible to
tell them that well laverne thank you so
much for being part of this conversation
i hope it's the first of many uh and i
look forward to our partnership our
journey doing all of the things that uh
we talked about it and more uh and as we
said is you know there's sometimes
people get cynical about education but i
i've never been more optimistic so thank
you so much
well it is such a pleasure to be on your
show and to work with yourself so thank
you for having me
well thanks everyone for joining um
especially it's been a little while
since we did one of these others i was
on vacation i went to joshua tree very
very nice highly recommend it um
actually i'm gonna post a video on it on
my new tiktok account i was very
dismissive of tick tock until i tried it
out and now i'm kind of i think getting
it
uh but thanks for joining and i look
forward to seeing you all
shortly for our next um
uh homeroom live stream which i think
will be uh next week but i will see
y'all then
you